well we start here with the events of
saturday you know with with the council
ongoing as i said in a recount in
georgia not even started
legal challenges still being mounted in
other words when the matter of who
actually won the election was still
very much up in the air the media
decided that it seemed enough and
declared joe biden
the winner now as to this decision i
will maintain my
radical stance that we can never know
who won any election
until all legal votes have been counted
and accusations of improprieties have
been
investigated and litigated um that
hasn't happened yet in this case so we
remain in limbo whether the media
chooses to acknowledge it or not
but none of that stopped joe biden from
taking to the stage delivering his
victory speech
a speech that i thought was breathtaking
in its dishonesty phoniness
arrogance granted the dishonesty
funniness arrogance
this is the general tenor of almost any
political victory speech or political
speech of any other
any other kind but this one managed to
raise the bar
by several notches i think let's listen
to uh some of the speech i'm sorry to do
this to you but uh
i must so let's let's listen tonight
we're seeing all over this nation all
cities and all parts of the country
indeed across the world an outpouring of
joy
of hope renewed faith and tomorrow bring
a better day
okay let's stop it there for just a
moment uh yes about that about that
outpouring of joy in cities across the
country
it was an outpouring of something
certainly joy is one word for it not the
word i would use but one word
here's footage of one such outpouring
this is in dc thousands of people all
crammed together i'm told there's a lot
of dancing in the street
they were so happy they were dancing
good for them
i guess if you're a business owner in
one of these cities you'd rather have
them
drinking in celebration from the wine
bottles than lighting them on fire and
throwing them through your windows so
that's an improvement but of course
the question does arise as you look at
these images did joe biden defeat covet
that quickly
i knew it'd be quick i mean he did
promise to shut down the virus i just
didn't think it'd
take him 30 minutes to do it that's
pretty impressive or is this
yet another example of the chronovirus
being politically enlightened you know
we already knew that it will spare you
if you're a blm activist or a mourner at
a funeral for a prominent democrat
will also pass over you like the angel
of death in egypt if you're expressing
joy about donald trump
allegedly being voted out of office is
this
you know the coronavirus being
politically enlightened or even just
kind of chill
maybe it's going hey you know they're
having a good time i'm not going to go
getting them all sick and stuff bro
let's
let's not ruin the party okay now i i
can
make a joke about it but it's actually
not funny especially if your child has
been going to school on his computer for
a year
not getting a real education or your
grandfather had to die alone with no
visitors or
your business was destroyed all of that
had to happen they told us to keep us
safe
but these clowns can have their party in
the middle of the street
oh and remember a lot of these people
are the same ones
who are too afraid to go to the polls to
vote they were too afraid to participate
in the election in person
but not too afraid to celebrate the
ostensible result
of the election in person right it's a
farce it's a travesty
speaking of farces back to joe's speech
i pledge to be a president who seeks not
to divide
but unify who doesn't see red states in
blue states
only sees the united states
and worked with all my heart with the
confidence
of the whole people to win the
confidence of all of you
and for that is what america i believe
is about
it's about people and that's
what our administration will be all
about i sought this office
to restore the soul of america to
rebuild the backbone
of this nation the middle class and to
make america respected around the world
again
and to unite us here at home now parts
of that were indecipherable uh par for
the course of course he's a
dementia patient and it was past sundown
but from from what i could gather biden
wants to unite us heal us bring us
together
and quote restore our soul i'm not sure
how a soul is restored much less how a
president can do it is it something
that you do through executive order
legislation the soul restoration act of
2021 is that what's coming
but let's not get bogged down on the
details i guess the point simply is that
we didn't have souls before and now we
do because a 78 year old career
politician
says he's our new president you know
there's this long-standing theological
debate very interesting about insolent
um when does the soul enter the human
body is it at conception some other
point
well it turns out it's not conception
it's election the election of joe biden
that's how we all get souls
good to have that sorted out finally now
joe believes
he's onto something with this schtick
he's been tweeting like a fortune cookie
for the past 48 hours declaring that
we're now
united strengthened healed
we have full hearts and steady hands he
said we are running
arm in arm through fields of daffodils
rainbows stretched across the sky
unicorns fly overhead all is right in
the world now because uncle joe is here
to sniff our hair
and tell us it's okay the media has
dutifully latched on to this theme as
well um a time to heal
announces the time magazine cover and
the
vaguely sentient bag of farts uh new
york mayor bill de blasio
also came out to celebrate our
liberation by joe biden
and our opportunity to heal here's what
he had to say
liberation it's just joyous people have
felt this weight
and a sense of we're divided and we we
shouldn't be that way and now there's a
feeling that anything's possible
that we can heal again that we can move
forward and look joe biden
and kamala harris did something amazing
this is turning out to be a
huge victory all over the country but
it's also the beginning of the healing
that's what we need in this country this
city everywhere but you know it's an odd
thing this healing this unity this
liberation
even as biden lays his healing hands
upon us
and keeps them there for an
uncomfortably long time other democrats
like alexandria or cortez
are busy compiling enemies lists of
people who supported trump something
called the trump accountability project
has been formed
for the purpose of blacklisting anyone
who committed the crime of wrong think
over the past four years
it appears that before we can hold hands
and and amid the flowers and sing our
songs of joy
a few say 70 million or so heretics must
be burned at the stake
joe forgot to mention that part the
healing will commence only after his
enemies have been brought before him in
slain
but i suppose that doesn't sound quite
as inspiring in a speech and that's all
this unity and healing stuff really is
it's
fodder for speeches and these are
speeches given by a man
who belongs to the ideological and
political club which has for the past
several years
insisted that all of their opponents are
bigots racist or worse and not worthy of
acceptance in polite society
anyone who threatens their agenda or
defies their wishes can be slandered
smeared ripped to shreds
labeled a gang rapist even if that's
what it takes and he will deserve it
because he is in fact worse than a gang
rapist
he is in he's an inconvenience to them
in recent months they've taken this
machiavellian gospel to the streets
burning and looting
making victims of their fellow americans
none of whom did anything in particular
to incur their wrath
these are people who will tell you that
if you belong to a certain race
white and sex male you are fundamentally
and irretrievably broken
you are racist by your very nature
probably sexist too
and they've told us we can't come
together under the flag or as americans
because america is systemically racist a
global disgrace
its heroes are all monsters whose
monuments must be defiled and destroyed
but now a man steps out from among this
group of marauders and bullies and
arsonists and thieves and smear
merchants
and bids us to unite unite around what
for what what commonality what shared
sense of purpose what universal goal or
value is supposed to bind us together
right now joe
i wouldn't know how to unite with joe
biden and his ilk even if i wanted to
which frankly i don't
mainly because i know the answer to my
own questions
we are meant to unite in submission
to the democrat party and its doctrines
we are meant to come together
around the democrats and they're a
hollow vessel of a leader to say
congratulations
and hooray and we agree and about four
or five other approved
sentiments this is the unity for which
joe biden pleads
i have won so now we can be friends as
long as you follow the orders
he he says to us with a magnanimous
smile
well call me ungrateful but i don't find
this pitch very appealing
nor believable i don't like division
but i'll take it over a false and empty
unity
around a false and empty man
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content